ωτον μιλιαλείτε να μας μιλήσει γα οσύνταγμα ή το εξέρωγ να φέρω των τώρα ναρείτε
να μας μιήσει για το ανθρώπει κατράύματα και για τις συνες θηματική περευγή πουν τομε
καλύτερο πρόβλεμαν τούτοτου τόπου να θέλεις να πάε μετάει πέσε ότι επροσκαι στων αντρινα τον
κοσταντίνο ναι ένα στέλεγχος το οποίον πορεί να ανυποψήβειος βουλευτίσμε ο συναγελμό τάξει το κρά
τον κόσταντίνυ μαζί πο θα ρτ να πα είναι υπερπατητώς ναι ναιάρα ο χριστόφονος νθα
διστάσει να προσεγγήσει άτομα και που το συναγελμό κι π ποιο δήποτε κόμμα αερκεί να
είναι άξια όω λέα είναι αν είναι κάποιος κι είμαιο κοπελούη ν έχει κάποιο να
φγεημα πργάμε στις ζωή του α φύγημα πορώ κάτι έκαμε τος άνθρωπος ωσποι ατις που
για με χωρίς τίποτα μηδε τον παραμο π μιαλιγο γα εναια προβλεματική αιμεγάλος αμέσα στη
εγώ καάθεραγα ια νεταιρία κανο κέρδος είναι πρώταθρίς κι πρους τον πόξι με έτσι μέτσι
επέτυχα ετώς αθρωι να φύγημαλεσο που το χαιρό τώρο να φύγε μως το καλύτρο έχει
κάποιον πρείνει πολιτπο που τον επροσέγκισες να κοντάσουν κναμένα πομέα που τους πολιτικούς ούλους ας
πούμε τώρα μεα μερωτά σας πούμε καιο που θαυμά ους οκρές κιμου κι το στήλμονο
φέδονας που υν πάφ δενα μαζήσουμε στην κίνηση με στο κόμμα για εμόνες βλευτικές έχκοίτα
ξε το πράμα που ο λέο δεν έχω δεν έχει να ν θέλω να έχω
σχέσει με πολιτικούς παγιούς καιπατ εσερωτο επιε κάποιο ίπαση ν ότι εία να χρεώσουν το
χριστόφρο ότι να κάνει με τον τάδετοντάεριοντάδε μια γκίνιεν σε πράγματαόντά δεμ εξετάτε δεαδ αν
καταφέρω και βρω του αδατάδομα που φαντάζζουμε δηλαδή να έχουνε αναφύγημα να να ενεπίχειρεματίρες νακάμα
κάτι στης ζωή τους να ξέρουν πνομικά να ξέρουν πουτε ενποιο θέλω να έχουνα ποιο
κάοιμα ότε να κάμιααλλά πάνω αό όλα ρεφινα δουλ πάω από όλα ρεφιρε τα ναφφεντικήρεφιλ
να ρώε αυτός τους ναδίναι φκαίνουν να μιλούν και να ξέρεις ότι μιλάς μα ζί
τους όρεί με το αλλο μαζί του το το πράγματα